triangulaire nom féminin désignant une
élection ou trois candidats sont
toujours un disto second tour sortez vos
calculettes les autres combats petite
plongée dans des calculs politiques en
matière électorale
la triangulaire est loin d'être la
quadrature du cercle
sauf pour la présidentielle pour les
municipales les acteurs de ce triangle
pas du tout du tout amoureux sont ceux
qui ont obtenu lors du premier tour au
moins j 10 % des votes selon la règle je
sais c'est facile
ils ont donc le droit de se présenter
pour vous au second tour la triangulaire
c'est avant tout une affaire d'ego dans
cette course à croix au mandat il en a
au moins deux qui ne veulent pas se
désister
il avait demandé la police le clip est
pas si les trois partis du second tour
se détestent il y en a deux qui se
détestent encore plus et souvent c'est
parce qu'ils ont tourné en rond sans
parvenir à un accord pour fusionner
leurs listes
en politique les angles c'est difficile
à arrondir le résultat d'une
triangulaire c'est rarement une équation
à plusieurs inconnues en général elle
propulse le troisième en ligne droite
vers le monde a brouillé les deux autres
essais annulant dans les yeux c'est
mathématique une faune croix sur la
victoire
il ne leur esprit qu'à vivre une
existence politique parallèle dans
l'opposition